hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a fun weekend of either
seeing or maybe not seeing Fantastic
Four so I'm gonna talk about some Easter
eggs from that but I really wanted to
talk about Deadpool and x-force yes
there is an x-force movie that's in
development it's just kind of gotten
pushed off to the side because of all
the x-men apocalypse stuff going on
right now before last year's comic-con
of 2014 we in a way before Deadpool
footage leaked before all that stuff
happened
Fox announced the next several release
dates for x-men based movies part of
that slate was x-force being developed
with the guy that did kick ass to jeff
wadlow they hadn't really picked a
director they just they announced that
they had hired jeff wadlow to start the
script chase that timeline to December
and Rob Liefeld via x-force creator
Deadpool creator says that he's read a
draft of the script so like there is
actually a draft of an x-force movie out
there but within a couple days of that
Bryan Singer announced that they were
making x-men apocalypse so I think based
on the success of Days of Future past
Fox just shifted its priorities to put
all of its eggs in that x-men basket in
the simplest of terms x-force is a
spin-off of x-men but because of some of
the things they're doing with x-men
characters it gets a little confusing
because cable is such a big part of it I
know everyone wants to see cable in a
Deadpool movie I feel like you would
probably show up in x-force first for
those that don't know cable is the son
of Scott Summers and a clone of Jean
Grey named Madeline Pryor in the movie
universe that already sounds pretty
confusing just to explain like how did
Jean Grey get clone you know when did
they have a child well just look at what
they're doing with Jean Grey right now
sophie turner is the new Jean Grey
clearly not quite old enough to be
having children
Scott Summers right now like they're
basically they're in the 80s and x-men
apocalypse so it looks like the
beginnings of their relationship so
children are like way way off in the
distance that is probably why x-force
Scott shelves because Fox wants to use
the cable character but it has to wait
till he can logically rise from that
universe and they just did a big time
travel movie cable himself is a big time
travel character he's like a
time-traveling man of action it's kind
of like if the drill sergeant from Full
Metal Jacket became a mutant if you
remember what the future timeline looked
like in Days of Future past the very
post-apocalyptic and then you have age
apocalypse in the comics which is also
you know very similar post-apocalyptic
timeline cable was born out of things
like that so that that's why he's so
hardcore so it's so crazy goes down
with apocalypse you you can't get to
cable so right now he's writing the
bench but I do think you know within
like two or three years they could
totally do an x-force movie for the most
part it seems like sophie turner like
these younger characters they're trying
to make them the new main cast so like
when we see a sequel to x-men apocalypse
it'll be with these young characters
again so it just makes things a little
more complicated with cable because it's
like if clearly they want to use all
these really young characters that how
is it that you're gonna explain this
crazy child from the future hell-bent on
taking down evil mutants when things
have not gone crazy and you've just done
like a big time travel movie so I think
that they're just trying to put some
distance between this and Days of Future
past the other alternative would be to
do an x-force movie in like another two
years and then just bring cable on let
him be cable and not completely explain
who he is or who his parents are to like
the sequel movie that'd be like a game
of Thrones situation where a lot of the
audience has already read the stories
they know where he comes from but the
majority of the movie going public has
no idea who cables parents are so he's
just this mystery crazy hardcore
character if Game of Thrones couldn't
survive a situation like that but you
know we're like a lot of the fandom has
already read the story that they're
doing and it can still be super popular
I think that x-men and x-force can do it
too because there is no way that they're
gonna do an x-force movie without doing
cable you guys can let me know how do
you think that they should explain cable
his existence when Jean Grey and Scott
Summers are teenagers right now and they
just did a time travel movie I feel like
if they went the hardcore comic book
route they would cast Liam Neeson his
cable and he would show up doing a
version of his taken character I have a
very particular set of skills can you
just see him showing up and kicking
sophie turner and all these young
mutants and their asses the other big
thing about cable is strife he's he's
like an evil clone of cable i think they
would sidestep him for for quite a while
maybe if they got to a third x-force
film they could bring him out but I feel
like cable just at his core works really
good as this hardcore of mutant
drill-sergeant fighting amongst the more
hardcore factions of mutants and as for
rounding the cast out
original lineup was boom-boom cable
cannonball domino ferrule shatter star
and warpath there's also sunspot and
siren and we actually saw a couple of
those characters in Days of Future past
and in the future time line so Bryan
Singer actually kind of laid some of the
track work for the original x-force team
but logically what they try to do just
because there are so many x-men universe
characters that Fox hasn't been able to
get to yet so they probably use it as an
opportunity to develop new characters
that they haven't done on-screen at all
before and then also let some of the
other minor characters cross over some
of the characters that we saw from the
future timeline of Days of Future past
some of the new x-men apocalypse
characters I feel like Olivia Munn
couldn't open an x-men film by herself
but she would do really well in a much
bigger role in x-force she's playing
Psylocke for those that didn't know she
actually she didn't join x-force till
2010 but I've you know I feel like
depending on how strong the actors are
that they get for x-men apocalypse they
can just help boost any x-force spin-off
that they do but you guys can let me
know would you be okay with them being
characters that weren't on the original
x-force team like Evan Peters is amazing
but Quicksilver was never like a huge
character in the x-force comics
either way the reality is is that we
probably won't see an x-force movie till
we get closer to the second Deadpool
movie like if Deadpool is as successful
as everyone thinks it's gonna be they'll
roll out a sequel within two years I
think you know around that same time is
when we would see the x-force film if
you want to read some really cool
explore stories they're actually pretty
friendly in terms of film adaptation you
can start with a force to be reckoned
with that's New Mutants 98 to 100 and
x-force number one to four it's a pretty
simple sell it's the origin of the
original comic book x-force team
there's the apocalypse solution in the
Dark Angel saga that's uncanny x-force
number one 2:18 this is after Wolverine
and Psylocke were on the team so they
they might have to swap a couple
characters Psylocke would totally work
Wolverine not gonna be around that much
longer unless they recast the character
and then more recently there's the
wanted storyline that's cable and
x-force number one to five the story's
kind of like Ocean's eleven meets fast
and furious a fast and furious Marvel
movie actually does sound pretty badass
so despite terrible movie
there's still lots of awesome stuff
going on in Fox's universe of characters
you have all the Deadpool stuff you have
x-force on the horizon we know x-men
apocalypse is dropping next year so get
really pumped about that and there's an
x-men TV show that they're trying to
negotiate the rights for with Marvel so
in case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for my Fantastic Four hail
Hydra review and you can click here to
watch the Deadpool trailer again 10 or
15 more times hopefully that'll be a
good antidote for a bad Fantastic Four
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you